here that that is the sound of a
groundbreaking scientific device it's
called a paper fuse
that's a centrifuge made of paper and
like a traditional centrifuge it works
by separating the contents of biological
samples by spinning really really fast
that's an important first step for
diagnosing illnesses like malaria and
HIV the new Prakash is a bioengineer at
stanford where he spends a lot of time
thinking about how to make science
affordable and accessible so to me
frugal science is really designing with
constraints in mind when we see bringing
tools to the masses we truly do mean
billions of people on the planet
commercial centrifuges are heavy you
need electricity to power them and it
can cost thousands of dollars and a lot
of places in the world you can't power
afford or transport a traditional
centrifuge and we told ourselves we're
going to design one but it cannot
require any electricity because of the
places we work in it needs to be
completely light and portable that I
could carry it in my pocket and it had
to cost less than a dollar in parts so
we could actually scale the
manufacturing by boxing ourselves in
with constraints we can think outside
the box health workers can load a blood
sample and with very little force power
the paper feed by hand
I have a simple glass capillary with
some beads and glass in water and I'm
going to take this capillary and put it
right here and at this point I'm just
going to spin this and if this was a
blood sample and I would spin it roughly
at the speed for say a minute I should
be able to get the entire contents of
that blood all the RBC separate out from
the plasma so here is the capillary and
all the beads are all the way in a
really really narrow band up here and
then the completely empty fluid is right
on top paper fuses based on a classic
toy called a whirligig the design has
been around for thousands of years but
it wasn't until very recently that
anyone developed a physical model for
how it works
conventionally a string has a
geometrical limit to what it can coil
and beyond that geometrical limit the
number of twists going beyond that limit
will pop the string in the third
dimension and it will start coiling in a
hierarchical structure which is a coil
of coils this is called supercoiling
supercoiling turbocharges the paper fuge
up to speeds of 125,000 rotations per
minute that's enough to generate 30,000
Gees enough to isolate malaria parasites
in a matter of minute
I find it quite fascinating to see the
simplicity and toys and exploit those
mechanisms in tools that we make because
sometimes the simple solutions problem
are more powerful than a conventional
off-the-shelf way of thinking about it